alors j'en ressors comme vous êtes en
très bonne santé tout le monde peut le
constater c'est le moment de vous faire
l'interview jugement dernière c'est
l'heure du jugement dernier
jean hétu près pas encore mais bon genre
oui as-tu plus en moi à une époque oui
pourquoi as-tu cessé de croire en moi
gens parce que j'ai cessé parce que j'y
ai cru en vous par trouille de la mort
et je sais que vous n'arrangerait rien
là haut tu fais chier gens as-tu déjà
pêché par penser par action par omission
ou à la mouche pêcher à la mouche jamais
par omission jamais ai pas repensé tout
le temps jean as-tu foutu en l'air un
tournage en prétextant un quelconque mal
au dos
non j'ai foutu en l'air un tournage en
prétextant une douleur dans le périnée
qui est située entre l'anus et les
testicules à saint jean as tu déjà
participé à des émissions de télévision
sous l'emprise de substances illicites
non mais ce soir j'aurais dû
non as tu déjà regardé tf1 le samedi
soir en deuxième partie de soirée
non non jamais pourvu que ça dure as-tu
déjà commis l'acte de chair sans volonté
reproductrices oui de nombreuses fois
les gens gardent un souvenir épatant
mais la plaie jean desailly et n'est pas
là cités les journaux série va bien
genre as-tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non je ne suis pas un trompeur j'ai eu
des grandes passions
mais je ne trompais pas je partais est
ce que tu te repent de tous tes péchés
gens non c'était le plus agréable
dans ce mail dont il s'agit